vemos el vídeo anterior con el escenario
en donde la compañía quiere comprar a la
compañía vez pero no lo van a hacer con
efectivo lo van a hacer con sus acciones
el problema nos dice que la compañía va
a adquirir la compañía ve por 60
millones en acciones de la compañía
y quieren dar un precio premium en el
mercado actual para que eso sea
atractivo a los accionistas de la
empresa ve para que digan vaya ese es un
muy buen negocio ese es un 20 por ciento
más de nuestro precio actual en el
mercado existen dispuestos a aceptar esa
es una transacción de acciones en la que
los accionistas recibirán exactamente 60
millones de dólares lo que va a suceder
es que la compañía
va a expedir 2 millones en acciones y
esos 2 millones en acciones que valen 30
dólares por acción
en teoría se pueden vender en el mercado
actual y obtener los 60 millones en
efectivo pero en lugar de hacer esto y
comprar la compañía ve en efectivo van a
tomar directamente estas acciones y se
las van a cambiar por todas las acciones
que los accionistas de la compañía ve
tiene
esencialmente adquiriendo la compañía
mediante las acciones así que hacia el
momento de cerrar el trato el precio de
las acciones de la compañía pasa de 30 a
35 dólares por acción entonces el precio
de la transacción si ustedes piensan en
el valor de las acciones que recibirán
los accionistas de la compañía ve el
precio en el mercado será de 70 millones
de dólares si por el contrario el precio
de las acciones de la compañía baja a 25
por acción ellos solamente van a recibir
50 millones de dólares en acciones lo
que quiero que pensemos en esa situación
es que es lo que debería pasar con las
acciones de la compañía ve antes de que
se cierre la transacción si es que
asumimos que todos van a creer que si se
va a llevar a cabo esta transacción
voy a graficar las acciones aquí
esto es el precio
ese es el tiempo
permíteme dibujar el precio de la
compañía ve en donde en este momento se
está comprando 50 dólares
es la compañía ve y ahora la compañía
se está comprando a 30 dólares la acción
y noten que aunque el precio de las
acciones de la compañía está por debajo
de la compañía de la compañía tiene una
mayor cantidad de acciones en el mercado
pues es una empresa más grande y es por
eso que no suena extraño que quieran
comprar a la compañía ve bueno ese es el
día en el que se hace el anuncio vamos a
asumir que todos piensen que la
transacción se va a realizar que por
cada acción bebé que tiene cada
accionista recibirá dos acciones de la
compañía así que si la compañía
hace esto qué es lo que sucedería con el
precio de las acciones de la compañía ve
si todos están totalmente seguros de que
la transacción se va a llevar a cabo
bueno cada accionista debe o cada acción
debe va a ser convertida en dos acciones
de a
por lo que después de ese punto en el
tiempo con la seguridad de cada
transacción se va a realizar cada una de
las acciones debe va a valer dos
acciones de a así que deberán negociarse
exactamente al doble del valor de las
acciones de a justo cuando se anunció la
transacción y todos asumen que va a
ocurrir el precio de las acciones debe
inmediatamente va a aumentar hasta 60
dólares la acción y a partir de ahí
siempre deberán negociar las algo hablé
de las acciones de a
si las convencieron a menos del doble de
las acciones de a entonces en lugar de
comprar las acciones de la gente
preferirá contra las acciones debe o
comprarían la mitad de las acciones de
venta imaginemos que alguien quiere
comprar dos de las acciones de a y se da
cuenta que las acciones debe están a
menos de la mitad que las acciones de
'la pero que van a valer más que las
acciones de a en el futuro debido a esta
transacción por lo que preferirá a
comprar las acciones debe en lugar de
las de a ya que si todos asumen que esto
va a ocurrir antes de que la transacción
se lleve a cabo las acciones debe
deberán valer el doble exactamente el
doble que las acciones de a